i would say all the jobs are definitely
in china with the uyghur muslims
producing a lot of the corporate
american goods that lecture us
on racism here in the united states
which is something that people need to
realize as well but
i don't know if we want to go into the
next story but i mean they infiltrate
not only these kind of intellectual
institutions that kind of set
uh our young children to be where they
are
right now china has a huge influence on
the universities and colleges
but they also infiltrate politicians in
more ways than
one as well what are you getting today
with the chinese spy
oh that's right oh no wall well has the
nerve to say
cheat an election when he had a
fundraiser organized by a chinese spy
yes and there's accusations by donald
trump jr that allegedly this spy had
relations with mr eric swalwell which by
the way
eric swalwell was one of the biggest
proponents of russian collusion if you
remember he was out there on all the
media networks they loved him he was
ranting and raving there's a foreign
government
infiltrating our government there's a
foreign government controlling
everything luke the russians
are colluding he fights he farted on tv
while accusing the very arc of trying
exactly
and at the same time he was being
infiltrated at very high levels
by a chinese government which he had
very close
dealings with now this person is very
interesting because
they they are describing her as a honey
pot she slept with many prominent
government officials
and she escaped to china as soon as the
fbi came looking for her they saw that
she somehow miraculously
escaped which is absolutely juggling so
the biden families compromised
dianne feinstein had a chinese spy
working for office and now swalwell and
many other people had a spy working
forum
secretary pompeo said that chinese
governments infiltrated every level of
government
not just not just infiltrated i mean
this spy was deemed an important
political figure in california
she was orchestrating a lot of the
campaigns a lot of the fundraisers
raising for swallowing
exactly so there's individuals right now
saying suawell needs to resign
immediately since he's been infiltrated
the mainstream media right now is is
slowly patting him on the back saying
it's okay
he's a victim here he was given a
briefing by the fbi
they didn't do that for trump yep when
when trump was accused of russia they
just started spying on the fbi called
him and notified him that he was
infiltrated by the chinese government
and we still don't know exactly what
this person has we don't know what
information they were able to gather
this person also did fundraisers for
tulsi gabbard of all people wow
yes so this is a major big story
that's going to have a lot of
ramifications because when you look at
the beijing professor he also
talked about a political figure that
helped him out
tremendously that now has chinese
citizens and that was back in china so
we saw this beijing professor literally
talk about this
gloating about this acting very happy
that this happened
and now we have this story that just
came out there and uh i think this
probably happened
a couple weeks ago maybe even a couple
of months ago and now we're just finding
out about it because there's a
correlation with it
you just make me more pessimistic about
the whole china thing well i mean i'd
rather
know the truth and reality that we're
facing than be blind
to exactly what's going on because we
have to understand our institutions are
corrupted to the core
and they need to be replaced immediately
listen listen if you just praise the
glory that is the chinese communist
party then you'll get to be a wealthy
party member
you'll have a nice loft top the tallest
building
i wouldn't just feel right you know
imprisoning the leaders
i wouldn't feel right in prisoning the
poor but what if it's people would would
you rather go to the gulag yourself
all you have to do is give in you just
give in no thank you
that's what's happening though it's it's
it's the way people feel it's a path of
least resistance
why bother fighting against this machine
that is that is
you know gaining strength and taking
over when you can just give in and be
rich
right i mean that's how they went over
the elites so
yeah well we're talking about the spying
program that was revealed
today with the chinese honey pot that's
infiltrated more ways than one a lot of
us government officials
what do you think about that because a
lot of people are saying this is
room for sualwell to resign like swallow
or redesign do you think that's
legitimate do you think there's any
legal merit in that
i mean there's there's not a legal it's
not a legal argument it's a political
argument
i think you should resign i think this
should be looked at like i think you
should have resigned a long time ago
like you you had a
you were compromised by a russian spy in
the middle of the cold war yeah
time for you to resign yeah like in you
know i mean but i'm in general think
a lot more people in our government
should be resigning i think they should
all resign right like yeah and term like
retiring from public life like why
hasn't bill crystal retired from public
seriously or henry kissinger of all
people he got fired by trump
his organization did because he's 90
doesn't he have grandchildren he can
hang out with him it's fine
is it doesn't it seem like trump is i'll
say this in my opinion trump is doing
everything he's doing he's acting as
though he's not going anywhere
i mean i think that's it i think it's a
front honestly i think he'll
you know remember that he was a
billionaire and he gave up the life of a
billionaire and he'll be returning to
the life of a billionaire for the most
part
um yeah but i don't know the the the the
tds individuals are going to go after
them like the state yeah
right the state prosecutors um there's a
bunch of them they're nuts
like we're like that's what i'm saying
man i i can't imagine
everything just goes back to normal the
way some of these people like these
democrat voters think is going to happen
because yeah they're like the calls for
unity like i'm sorry like you don't get
to call us nazis one day and then
suddenly have me turn around and sing
kumbaya with you but they think it's
going to calm down when you've literally
got
you know linwood and cindy powell
friends and saying don't vote republican
oh my gosh i mean that said like and
there's stuff like i'm seeing like calls
for martial law
and um you know like i i'm not for any
of that like
in that respect i'm just like count me
out like i'm not gonna sit here and
well we gotta be honest here if the
republicans were accused of stealing the
election
i think half of america would be burned
down by now oh yeah sure right like that
i mean
but you know that's also like the
consequence of that like if
what you're calling for is like martial
law and a re-vote the con
and if you actually prevailed then half
of america would be burned down
if trump succeeds in his efforts
and you know becomes president yeah it's
going to be anti-fun times 10 times
and i mean like i i mean that's not
that's not independently a reason right
the question is like i i
the reason i oppose that is not like oh
well antifa is bad and they'll do bad
things it's not
you know we shouldn't let that control
our behavior and decision making but
uh that doesn't mean i i want to live in
a country with cous
or uh sort of what do you what do you
what look if if trump on january 21st
is a regular guy again the new new
york's going after him like crazy
and and the media smears and lies about
him it's intense
i don't know i mean it's just you you
remember everybody hated nixon and then
they stopped and they forgot after the
forward pardon
i could even see a biden pardon of trump
honestly that's federal level what about
the state
the state legislation part of the state
level but i think i think the
the sort of urgency and onus to keep
going after trump is gone if he's not
president anymore
i think perhaps that's my i mean i might
be wrong but i don't i don't think so
though because i think they need their
boogeyman they need their villain and
and and you know the articles that are
coming out right now from left say
in order for us to heal trump must go to
prison
yeah no a lot of a lot of hot takes
coming from the left on there they've
been calling for things like truth and
reconciliation commissions
tribunals tribunals like so like so he's
like hideki tojo
i'll say i'll say a couple things you
wanna you know uh you
by all means call out the people saying
we have martial law right yeah the
democrats have already implemented it in
many states
oh you know over covered right and then
you add that to the fact now they're
saying tribunals
for not just trump but his enablers and
some people have gone so far as they put
a list of their supporters
so that would be you me or or even luke
even though luke's not a trump supporter
it doesn't matter
you've called out china you've been
critical of the left therefore it's good
enough for them
ian who's actually kind of a hippie dude
they'd say doesn't matter he's on the
teamcast irl show put them on the list
of enablers and supporters so if
if we're at the point where we already
have martial law locked in many places
in states that's violating the
constitution
they're calling for truth and
reconciliation commissions tribunals
and things like that and then on the
other side they're calling for martial
law
like how does this come go go down
i mean i don't know how it resolves i
think you know my hope
is collapse yeah i i i don't know what
i'm saying like the
resolve right like if you're making
predictions i don't know i mean i i
think
and there's a lot of other you know i
mean the the covet reorientation of
wealth to
the big companies versus people people
having nothing left are going to snap
like that viral video of the pineapple
uh hill woman
where she's got this outdoor seating
area that newsom's like you can't you
can't use it
and then right next to it is hollywood
food production services
totally fine regular people are looking
at that and their brains are gonna
explode
yeah and i wonder if the consequences
for that are finally gonna be felt in a
world where trump isn't around
like he's just he does have this effect
of like sucking all the air out of the
room and
that in terms of media coverage i mean
the thing about it's it is really deeply
offensive that gavin you know these
politicians can't adhere to their own
guidelines and they don't want to
it's also important to note that we saw
record levels of protest under the
obama administration when he first came
in we saw occupy wall street
so that's also another factor to really
consider here and also that a big swap
of the left is not really impressed with
biden at all
but i was going to ask you how do you
see this unfolding in the worst case
scenario
and how you see it unfolding in the best
case scenario i mean
worst case you get i mean i guess like
democrats are going to be in control the
federal government and republicans
generally don't do
like full-scale rebellion right and they
don't do cultural institutions and they
and they don't do cultural institutions
but they also don't do like antifa type
stuff in general like there isn't you
know you don't see the sort of burning
down of the cities and
so how would you let me know your
thoughts on this i think we might see
you know joe biden for instance he wants
to ban all online sales of guns and
accessories and ammo and things like
that
he wants to do what what you bullet
registration and a two hundred dollar
tax on
everything every gun nfl any yeah what
does national firearms act is out it is
or yes yes well
so that's why we need to make sure we
don't lose the damn senate
well so so what happens then if if he
does this if the senate does this if
they pack the courts
i wouldn't be surprised if a bunch of
jurisdictions small towns all of a
sudden had right-wing militias
i mean i think that that would be a
point where you'd actually see the sort
of rebellions that
you and like you know real serious
anti-government activity that's sort of
hinted at in the 90s under clinton
uh but that might become like a really
big and that's why we had the uh
what was it like what were the two you
had waco waco ruby
ruby ridge yeah but i think i mean my
guess is that's ultimately going to be
just talk i don't think biden's going to
sign new gun legislation i think that i
mean
democrats you don't think they'll pack
the supreme court i mean i think
i think if they had the power they would
do it um and i think the the big problem
there
is what you'll what though i don't know
if biden will do that stuff at the
federal level but what i expect will be
um in a world where the court is packed
dc versus heller gets overturned the
what is that one that's the court
decision that establishes that the right
to bear arms is an individual right and
not a collective one
so right so the collective right would
be like if there's a militia then you're
allowed to be in the military with guns
exactly um and it's scary that that
decision is even close like that i mean
that it requires real bastardization of
the grammar of the second
have you read the original second
amendment no the one that says why don't
we do whatever we want with guns
it's like it's like that uh parks and
rec ron swanson like
this when they were initially proposing
the bill of rights
there were like 17 articles that were
proposed the original second amendment
said
something to the effect of if someone
chooses not to join
active duty militia or military they
that they will still have the right to
bear arms
and they took that language out i guess
because there was a concern about
it could potentially mean people could
you could avoid conscription
so initially they were like you can bear
you know a well-regulated militia being
necessary to you know for a free state
the right to bear arms should not be
infringed and if an individual chooses
not to join
or be part of militia they shall still
have the right to bear arms and they're
like wait wait get rid of that part
because it makes it sound like you can
avoid conscription
and we need transcription because at the
time if you were an able-bodied male
it's like you're going to war buddy
so to get rid of it now we have these
arguments which i think
are completely in bad faith if you
actually look at the history of the
second amendment we had privateers we
had corsairs
like regular regular dudes like here's
my battleship i can use to blow up a
french you know
trade vessel regular citizens had
cannons on their houses and properties
and things like that so they could
now now it's like you can't have any of
that
and that's the argument but but also
defund the police because the police are
bad and and really just like let
yourself be at the mercy
of people that's why i think what we're
talking about is fifth generational
warfare
disarm the people and disarm their their
local police
why would you do that let me tell you
this in these west coast places
where they're very prominently doing
this portland seattle
places in california it's already hard
enough to get a gun
in california now you've got defund the
police
what do you think would happen if you
had northern california nobody's armed
well northern california is
fairly republican so people got a lot
probably have long guns but let's say
you have a city
very few people have guns and the police
are now defunded and fractured
anybody can walk right in
i've you know i'm from california i
would never move back
and it's it's sad to see what's happened
to the state i think
if you know they get the senate and i do
think they'll get it i do
because trump's not on the ticket look
at 2018. they didn't have
the the the uh with trump supporters are
not republicans
for the most part yeah but stacey abram
lost in 16 she lost to brian kemp
and 16. yeah i'm sorry that's true um
i mean and like i still you know i still
know
george has a red state in general i
think it just had a particular coalition
sort of like utah if like utah were a
closer state
utah was you know very mormon and and
had a big chunk of
you know trump underperformed his normal
the normal republican performance in
that state so i think george is kind of
similar in that respect where you've got
you know that big suburban atlanta
population
since you're a betting man what odds
would you give on georgia going
republican
going republican i'd say i mean 70
percent chance 75
chance wow i think that's what the uh
the batting odds are right now it's like
70
70 something sounds about right to me
right like you know when i was the funny
thing is i didn't bet on the origin of
the election
before the election because i thought
the odds were about right you know i
think trump was about a two to one dog
or something like that and i thought
that was right i have to say either way
it doesn't look
good because if you know the senate is
by one a majority of the republicans
how much dirt do the chinese have
especially with their honey pots on one
politician to persuade them or to push
them in to do whatever they want i mean
and they've been doing some crazy
stuff i mean they decided i still don't
understand this and why they would even
consider it they did the
mike lee's immigration bill where he
wanted to like remove country caps like
guys you get a grip we're trying to win
the senate here and you're out there
you're pushing liberalized immigration
policy when there's a republic
that's why i i i don't even think the
republicans are going to do enough to uh
defend the country i just i mean i don't
they want to watch out of them i just
expect them not to do things that are
all you know disastrous and catastrophic
because i mean
the way i look at it is democrats want
to completely remove the ability for
republicans to win elections
if you i don't know if you've read the
book it's time to fight dirty i might
have recommended it i don't know
but basically i mean what do they want
to do why they want to do it pack the
supreme court
add more states they can't control the
senate permanently uh
you know national voter read you know
automatic voter registration
hall voting day a holiday they want to
complete universal mail in voting
university and the argument is we want
to make all of it we make it easier for
people to vote and
that's that's just not true they're
trying to strip away election security
that's what they're doing
yeah and i mean but the the end goal
here is permanent democratic control
they thought they almost had it they
thought they were going to get it
one of the you know and that's actually
one of the arguments like why i don't
think the whole thing was
rigged you know in terms of like well
the voting machines are rigged well if
the voting
machines were rigged why didn't they
just get a result in line with polling
you know democrats underperformed public
polling in the run-up to the election
they could have
joe well yeah the polling was nuts
though
it was sure insane but like
it's easily explained in terms of the
you know the the the trump supporter can
more conspiracy mindset
the polls were propaganda to demoralize
voters
saying trump's gonna win don't bother
sure i agree then when it came to
actually
as trump has said this is their opinion
that he ended up winning
so well that they panicked and had to
really go crazy on you know cranking out
the fake votes just so story you know
everything right well i'm saying this
there's like that there is an
explanation
that the left is saying right now if
biden cheated then how come he that
democrats lost down ballot
well because there's a bunch of uh
undervotes votes that were just for
biden
right i mean and like i think there's
plenty of cheating on the fringe
right like i still think that you know i
watched poll watchers get denied entry i
watched how
frivolous like the behavior of these
democratic poll workers was and i'm like
these people could have
there's no moral thing that would have
stopped these people from doing some
amount of cheating if they could get
away with it
um the question is just what could they
get away with and i think
you know you end up getting away with
things like coheirs
absentee votes duplicate votes those
sort of
and then maybe some well they were in
philly they were putting up those signs
saying here's who you should vote for
yeah like that's like it's the weird
like it's like the cheating on the
margins or fraud in the margins versus
like fraud at the core
and i think that i haven't seen any good
evidence of fraud at the core i don't
think there's like proof of
you know these the the dominion
allegations but there's like yeah that's
that's the so wait
you know you know what really bothered
me about the dominion stuff is that i
even said this on the show i got really
mad about it
because the dominion stuff and and
hammer and scorecard
was a red herring it was it was
here's what happens there will be some
dirty politician
and they'll get caught doing something
illegal and when someone starts sniffing
too close
what they'll do is they'll throw out
some crazy idea to throw them off the
trail
and then instead of saying i caught this
dude doing drugs it turns into crazy
pizza cult at you know
in dc and now the real crime is they're
laughing
saying we trick those people how easy so
right now when you've got actual
irregularity and propriety
trump's suing and trying to be
legitimized in his claims
the single worst thing for donald trump
in all of this
was the lawsuit from sydney powell and
the dominion claims
because what trump needed and that's why
a lot of people it's funny they're
claiming that cindy powell is a democrat
lin was a democrat and they're like
trying to subvert trump
i tell you man i was uh i was reading a
post on reddit
and they said when it comes to a coup
the one thing a a a
leader and and you know the person
staging the coup need is legitimacy
the the current leader needs to tell
everyone i'm in charge i will always be
in charge listen to what i have to say
so that
the lower you know individuals the
police the law enforcement military
listen
what the other guy needs in the coup is
legitimacy
in the same regard here's why i'm
actually in charge listen to me
trump comes out and says 682 000 votes
no one was able to observe what's going
on here matthew brainerd's voter
integrity project look at all of these
votes from people who'd live in
different states and voted twice
that's legitimate then all of a sudden
sydney powell comes out with this typo
laden kraken lawsuit
that sounds crazy that has you know it's
almost impossible to back up except for
a bunch of youtube videos and a bunch of
weird videos popping up
and trump loses that legitimacy the
media jumped on that in two seconds
and tried making every claim for the
trump campaign about the fringes and
craziest conspiracy
to delegitimize his claim that he
actually won
and it worked yep yeah no i those
lawsuits are
a disaster they were i mean like and and
i had people in my mentions constantly
who knows if they're real or not
honestly but like people and i mentioned
being like how dare you say that this
won't work
and it's just like because i'm a lawyer
and i can these people are relief
the people are real i've i've know i
know people in my life i've talked to
people who are adamantly convinced the
dominion stuff is real i'll tell you
what maybe
sure but listen voter suppression too
for the georgia thing not to not sorry
interrupt but
right like you're suppressing your own
voters when you tell them that the
election is completely rigged
and you see what happened with ronald
mcdaniel and the lady was asking her
like why should we even bother voting
it's rigged
and she's like no no you have to vote
then you see uh sydney powell and lynn
wood
not only did they delegitimize trump's
claims
strongly not completely they're also now
telling people not to vote for
republicans
i mean it's just you know this is this
is the suicide caucus
like the the sort of we should just
commit electoral suicide because we
didn't get it maybe they're
accelerationists
maybe they are um they think look the
democrats take everything over the
sooner
the fat like here's the problem frogs
boiling in a pot
eventually just boil but you throw
boiling water water at a frog and the
frog is going to jump and run away
maybe that's what the accelerationists
think yeah yeah
i mean well maybe that's maybe that's
there's some big giant strategy but
really i think it's just a giant pr
exercise from people who've gotten high
on their own supply of pr
but what about trump you think trump's
trying to win though i mean i think he's
trying to win i just think i think he's
you know he's been a business man for a
long time he's a guy who's litigated a
bunch of cases to the end so he's
probably just like
he's doing what he does he's like any
other businessman he'll litigate hard as
long as he can until his appeals are
exhausted and then he'll comply that's
what i think
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you